le nouveau champion du monde de pétanque
christian andrianirina a été accueilli
en véritable rock star dans son club des
clayes-sous-bois pour célébrer son titre
glané en décembre dernier les dirigeants
organisent un tournoi au parc jean
carillon pour le sportif de 37 ans
licencié au club depuis 2012
c'est en tout cas moi ont peur parce que
déjà compte dans notés au pays il n'ya
pas même un seul club qui nous a fait
l'honneur de nous prendre dans leurs
clubs et tout ça mais pourtant ici c'est
ils ont fait quoi il faut savoir qu'il y
à peu près 50 50 et à pays qui
participent aux championnats du monde et
pour nous c'est une immense joie que
quelque chose d'inespéré le malgache sur
le mail on ovi neuf mois sur douze sur
son île natale et ne revient que trois
mois l'été dans les yvelines pour
participer aux principaux tournois
français le lien du sportif avec les
clayes-sous-bois est avant tout affectif
pour parler plus au bois bat y avait une
petite histoire avait créé avec le
président du club
il y avait c'était en 2012 il a fait
un tournoi de gala et on l'a gagné et du
coup ils étaient peut-être nous admirer
dans ce sens il a inhalé le prix de
notre club
christian driano y en a comme il vous
l'a dit nanou moi je considère un petit
peu comme mon fils c'est vraiment une
immense joie d'avoir un garçon qui allie
la simplicité l'humilité et la
gentillesse et bien sûr l'adresse de la
drees il en faudra encore pour garnir
une nouvelle fois la vitrine du club
nanou participera dès le mois de juillet
au masters scène